Hello everyone, this is Steve Gilbert. Welcome to lecture 4 on functions and decisions.
This week we're going to start moving away from writing input processing output programs
and start moving towards writing functions.
Now a function, you remember, is a named piece of code, like square root.
You can think of these, though, like mini IPO programs.
In other words, they still have input processing and output,
but the input processing and output is somewhat different.
So here are the major differences.
Instead of prompting the user, "Please tell me the number of boxes that you want,"
the input is going to come through the parameter list.
There's going to be no prompt and then waiting for the user to type input.
And then, instead of printing the output on the screen,
the output is going to be returned from the function.
Now, of course, you can still use functions to create IPO programs.
In fact, you're going to do this in one of the homework assignments.
You can have regular input and output,
but normally, unless we're writing an input and output function,
we won't do IO inside the function itself.
So let's look at arguments and parameters.
Now, most functions require extra information to do their work.
In other words, you couldn't just dial up Domino's or Pizza Hut and say,
"Send me a pizza," and not give them any extra information.
You'd have to tell them who you are, where to send the pizza to,
what size pizza you want, what, you know, toppings you want on the pizza, and so forth.
And so think of a function like square root.
Square root, when you call the square root function,
it doesn't stop and say, "Hello, what number would you like the square root on?"
It doesn't prompt you for input.
It also doesn't print its output on the screen.
Instead, square root gets its input through arguments and parameters.
Now, we're going to use these two terms in a very specific way.
Sometimes they're confused with each other,
and many times they're used in different ways.
But we're going to refer to arguments as the values that are supplied when a function is called,
not the variables that are created when the function is defined.
Those we're going to call parameters.
So when a function's defined, we're going to declare variables
that will be used inside the function to store the value.
Now, we have two kinds of functions.
We have fruitful functions or void functions.
A fruitful function is a function that produces a value.
That means we can call a fruitful function as part of an expression, as part of a calculation.
A void function, which is also known as a procedure, needs a side effect.
A void function would be something that says, you know, print this value.
It doesn't return anything.
It just does something.
So the does something part we call a side effect.
Now, we're going to do our first example here, our first exercise.
So make sure that you have gone into, got the lecture exercise document,
gone to Fridays, got the lecture exercise document,
clicked the link for the starter code,
and we'll look at this first problem we're going to do here.
So here, what we want to do is write a function called last digit.
Now, again, unlike the IPO programs we've written before in class,
we're not going to prompt the user, what digit do you want to process?
We're just going to pass the digit to the function last digit.
So if we give last digit a number like 3,572, the last digit in that number is 2,
and so that's the value it should return.
We also want it to work for negative numbers.
For instance, giving last digit -947 should return 7, not -7.
You can use one other function here.
You can use the abs function in C standard lib.
That's the version of abs that works for integers,
but no other library functions, and you can't use string.
So we couldn't take the substring at the size -1,
or the back function to get the integer.
So let's look at how we do this.
Let's open up in IC4, let's open up A, and let's open up last digit.cpp,
and we're going to write our function here.
Notice I've included only this one header we can have.
So how do we write a function?
Well, you always start with - so this is the function we're writing.
You always start with first draft skeleton.
The name for the skeleton is called a stub.
A stub doesn't actually do all of the work.
All it does is get the mechanical parts out of the way.
The reason you start with this first draft skeleton
is because you want to get the, again, the mechanical parts,
the part that you can memorize, you want that to be second nature,
just like driving a stick shift.
You want the shifting and using the clutch and so forth to be second nature.
And so that's what a stub is.
So here are the six questions we need to ask.
We need to ask first what kind of thing the function returns,
and write that down first.
In this case, last digit is going to return an int.
Secondly, we need to put in the name of the function.
Now, if we spell last digit with a lowercase d here,
it's not going to work, because our testing, or our client program,
is going to be calling the last digit function spelled exactly the way that is.
Third, we're going to put the input variable declaration,
the parameter declaration, inside parentheses following that.
And so these three parts, one, two, and three,
is going to create the interface for the function,
the part that describes it to the compiler.
The next part is going to create the body,
or the implementation of the function.
So you add braces to surround the function body.
Then, don't think at all about what the program is going to do.
Don't think at all about what the function is supposed to do.
Think about what kind of thing it is going to produce.
And so create a variable for the output, the result,
and initialize it, just a nothing, to an empty value, to zero.
Finally, return the result.
Then, once you make sure that compiles it and links,
you can test the program, and we can go in and complete it.
So let's walk through these steps so you can see them together.
So here's our function, lastDigit.
The first question is, what kind of thing that returns?
Well, it returns an int, so you just write that down.
Then we put in the name, lastDigit.
Then we put in the parameter.
Now this is going to take a digit.
It's going to be an int, so it's going to take a number.
So I'm going to say int number.
Notice this is what a parameter declaration looks like.
Just like a regular variable declaration,
except we don't put a semicolon there.
So int number.
So we did step one, two, and three.
The return type, what comes out, the name of the function,
and what goes into the function, the parameter declarations.
Step four is to create the implementation, the body.
Step five is to create the output.
So this is going to be an int.
So we're going to create the result.
We're going to initialize it to zero.
You can do it like that.
Either one of those is fine.
What you can't do is that.
If you do that, you have a random result.
You don't want to do that.
So we'll say int result, set it to zero.
And then step six, we're going to return the result.
Okay, so now we have our skeleton.
Let's test the skeleton to make sure it worked.
We're going to go over here.
We're going to open an integrated folder on A.
So now you notice that is switched to A.
I'm going to go here and I'm going to do make test.
Now you might be unhappy that you've got no points.
You should not be.
You should not be unhappy because what you've done is you've done all of the mechanical parts.
If it didn't compile at this point,
you'd know that you'd made some mistake in your stub, in your skeleton.
And you could concentrate on getting that right without worrying about what makes the program work.
So that's the whole beauty of this.
Create the mechanical part first and then do the stub.
So at one point you're concentrating on the syntax, getting that right.
The second point you're concentrating on figuring out how to get the program to work.
So let's think about how we get this program to work.
If we have a number, 35, 7, 67, I want the last digit here.
How do I get that 7 right there?
Well I get the 7 by taking, dividing the number by 10 and getting the remainder.
If I divide the number by 10, I get 356.
If I get the remainder, I get the 7 that's left over.
So I'm just going to set result equals number, remainder, 10.
And I'm going to try that again.
OK, let's clear the terminal with control L.
Let's do make test.
Oh, much better, I got 90.
But I have one of these tests that is failing here.
It's obvious why it's failing.
It's failing because I'm getting -7 here.
And so remember I told you that we could use this absolute value function for integers from there.
And so we're just going to put the absolute value of number, remainder, 10 into the argument there.
And we're going to make test once again.
And we have 100%.
When you're doing this, try to do it step by step as I've just showed you.
Don't start at the top and simply try and type out the answer from the beginning and end.
Do it in chunks like this.
Build the stub.
Make sure the mechanics work.
Do the simplest thing that will possibly work.
Result equals number, remainder, 10.
Then fix up the parts that don't work.
Do it incrementally.
That will really help you.
Now let's start talking about decisions.
So if you were writing a programming language, what parts do you need?
What features are required?
So you can write any programming language using three control structures.
This is from a paper that was written back in 1966 by Bohm and Jacopini.
So we have been writing programs so far using only one control structure - sequence.
That means we did our prompt, then our input, then our processing, then our output.
The statements were in order - the first, the second, the third, and so forth.
So that's what we've been doing with IPO programs.
The second kind of sequence, or the second kind of control structure that we're going to work on now, is called selection.
That's conditional execution with an if statement.
This is also sometimes called branching.
And then we're going to move on and look at iteration.
That's while looping.
So today we're going to start with selection.
Now to make a decision, we first have to think about conditions.
So decision making in C++ is based on these three foundations.
First, the built-in bool type returns true and false.
In Java this is called the boolean type.
I think in Python it's called bool as well.
Second, but in Python the true and false values are capital true and capital false.
In Java they're true and false, lowercase, like this.
Secondly, we have a group of operators called relational operators.
The relational operators compare values of any type, and they produce a boolean result.
Or a true/false result.
Finally, we have the logical operators.
The logical operators operate not on any kind of value, but only on boolean expressions, or true/false expressions.
And they combine them or negate them.
So the relational operators are operators like less than, greater than, greater than or equal, less than or equal, and equal.
And the logical operators are the operators and, and, or, and, not.
Now unfortunately, in C++ truthiness is a little bit more flexible than you might expect if you come from Python or if you come from Java.
So here's the problem, and I'm going to walk you through several different pitfalls.
Now, as with numbers, C++ has implicit bool conversions.
Now, Java has implicit numeric conversions.
In other words, it will automatically convert an int to a double, and you don't have to write a cast or anything like that.
But C++ will convert a number to a true/false value.
Something that Java won't do, and Python won't do.
So, if you have a number, and if the expression is false, if the number is anything other than zero, it is true.
If the number is zero, it's considered false.
So numbers and boolean values are implicitly converted.
Suppose I have a number, three, or a variable, a, that is a number.
And I want to assign that to a bool.
Well, if the number was zero, the bool variable will take on the value false.
If it's anything other than zero, a negative number or a positive number, it will be true.
Now, suppose I then take that bool variable, and I assign it to a number variable.
No matter what the number variable originally was, now if the bool was false, the number will be zero.
If the bool was true, the number will be one.
Now, in Java, if you print out a boolean variable, you'll get true and false.
The same thing is not true in C++.
In C++, the default is to print out zero and one.
Zero for false, one for true.
So if I print out a boolean variable, it will print out zero or one.
You can change that by using a manipulator.
You remember the manipulators we used for fix and set precision?
There's a bool alpha manipulator.
If you do that, it will use true and false, just like Java does.
So what are the pitfalls of this fact that numbers and boolean values are implicitly convertible?
Here's the first pitfall, an embedded assignment.
In Java, if we wrote this statement, if area equals zero,
now notice that I have the assignment operator there, not the equality operator.
In Java, Java would say, "Eh, that's not a boolean value.
You've made a mistake in your if statement."
In C++, it will actually assign zero to area,
and then when the if statement tries to go and evaluate, it'll say,
"Oh, I don't have a boolean here, but I have a number,
and I can convert that number to a boolean, and so this would be false."
If you assign a non-zero, then the condition is considered true.
Again, you're not told about this problem.
There is no warning.
Java, of course, will protect you from this, and C# will protect you from this.
They'll protect you from this as long as you're not comparing a boolean value to--
or a boolean variable to true and false, in which case you'll have the same problem.
So here's a question.
Let me ask you this.
I'll give you a few seconds.
Pause the screen and see if you can answer it, and then I'll talk about it.
Okay, so if a equals 3, if a equals 4, a is 4, which is weird,
because I just set it to 3, else a is not 4.
What prints?
a.
a is 4, weird.
b. a is not 4.
That's a syntax error.
It won't compile.
And d. neither one.
So pause for a few seconds and then come back, and we'll answer it.
Okay, welcome back.
So here I have an embedded assignment instead of a comparison.
When you read it, it says if a equals 4, of course it's not 4, it's 3,
so I'll go into the else and print a is not 4.
In fact, this assigns 4 to a, and then because that is nonzero,
the if statement considers it true.
And so we go into the truth part, and a prints out.
a is 4, weird.
So one of the pitfalls of convertibility between bools and numbers in C++.
Let me show you a couple other conditional pitfalls.
When you use the logical operators and and or,
it's possible to have both an impossible and an unavoidable condition.
The impossible condition is when you use and.
And if you use and, in this case,
I'm checking to see if a person is between 13 and 65,
but in fact that's not what I've written.
This is an impossible condition,
because the variable age cannot both be less than 13 and greater than 65.
It cannot be both of those.
Now we use the term and.
Make sure that person is under 13 and greater than 65.
We wouldn't say that.
However, we do use the term and and or kind of interchangeably in our informal speech.
And so you need to make sure every time you use and and or
that you double check to make sure you have a condition with and
that it's possible for all conditions to be true simultaneously.
This condition will always be false.
It's impossible.
Similarly, if you use or,
make sure it's possible for all conditions to be false simultaneously.
This condition here,
when you read it to yourself,
if age is greater than 13 or age is less than 65,
do something.
We read that kind of informally and it makes sense to us.
But we don't realize that every age must be either greater than 13 or less than 65.
There is no age that doesn't meet that condition.
So it's unavoidable.
Finally, because of this implicit conversion to Boolean,
it's very, very important to remember to always use complete relational expressions in conditions.
This is not a syntax error,
and it especially bites people who are Python programmers.
So we would read this if age is equal to 12 or 13 or 14,
and that would make sense to us when we read it.
But the compiler reads it if age equals 12,
now that's false,
or 13.
Well, we're not saying age equals equals 13.
We're just saying 13.
And remember the Boolean operators and and or operate on Boolean expressions.
So 13, even though it's a number here,
is treated as a Boolean expression.
It's not 0, therefore it's true.
So this is if false or true, and it's always true.
No matter what you do, no matter what value age it has,
this expression will always be true.
Let me give you another little quick check here.
We have a string grade set to C.
If grade equals equals A or A plus or A minus,
C out got an A.
Else if grade equals B or B plus or B minus,
C out got a B.
Else if grade equals C or C plus or C minus,
C out got a C.
What prints, assuming we have all the string includes and everything,
does it print got an A, got a B, got a C, or a syntax error?
So pause the video here, think about it, write down your answer,
and when you come back I'll answer it.
OK, welcome back.
So this is the same problem we just talked about on the last slide.
This is a Boolean expression, a relational expression.
So grade equals equals A is false.
Now the grade is not equal to A plus,
but this is not saying if grade equals equals A plus.
That is saying true.
It's not zero, it's true.
And so this is false or true, that whole expression is true,
so this will always print out got an A.
Let's look at another pitfall with comparison operators.
So here I've called the square root function
and stored the result in the variable root.
Now I'm taking the square root of 2,
and so if I multiply root times root,
I should get the square of 2,
or the square of the square root of 2,
or I should get 2.
And so this should print out OK.
Now this is syntactically comparable,
so I can compare this real number to this real number,
but if you simply write it down the way you learned it in mathematics,
you will get the wrong answer.
This will in fact print out back to Math 30,
because these answers will not exactly be 2.
And so there is no perfect solution.
In general, there's no perfect solution,
because real numbers are designed to work with very, very small numbers,
like a coronavirus,
and very, very large numbers, like the distance to far galaxies.
And so we cannot just have some simple value
and say if it's this close, it's OK.
So in general, you have to decide, based on the problem,
what's close enough.
We call that the epsilon value.
So here's a very common one,
1e^-14 is about the biggest difference that can be decided between two doubles.
Then you take the two numbers, if you want to see if they're equal,
root times root,
subtract it from 2.0,
and take the absolute value of that.
And if the absolute value is less than this epsilon value,
then the numbers are equivalently equal.
Now this might seem like a lot of work,
but it's in fact what you have to do.
It's not only what you have to do in C++,
it's what you have to do in Java and Python as well.
You simply cannot compare real numbers using the relational operators
and expect to get back a meaningful answer in every single case.
So if you care about correctness,
you'll make sure that you do this.
OK, so that's the Boolean type and some pitfalls with the Boolean type.
Let's go ahead and look at selection, so if statements.
Why do we want to use if statements in our code?
We use selection to control the flow of data.
We want to select a particular value or kind of value from a data flow.
For instance, we're getting all the transactions from a gas pump.
We want to select the debits or the credits.
How much do they owe us? How much did they pay us?
We do that with an if statement.
Now while this data is going by,
we may want to selectively update a counter or an accumulator.
We're looking at a string, and we want to count the vowels and the consonants.
We need to use an if statement to determine which counter to update.
We want to reduce root data to correct part of a program
in response to user commands or to input.
Oh, I got a credit in.
I want to send it to the part of the programs that processes a credit.
Oh, they checked three on the menu.
I want to go to the action that corresponds to three on the menu.
And finally, we use selection to error check data.
If the data that comes in is not within the bounds,
we would process it to a--we would send it to a place that would correct it.
So we'll use error checking.
We use selection to control error checking.
The important thing to realize about this is that selection produces information.
Selection is back to our old friend input, processing, and output.
When you come to a selection statement,
you have raw information before the selection statement--
raw data before the selection statement.
After the selection statement, things have changed.
You know some more information.
You know that I've found one more vowel
or that I've added something to the amount that the user has paid.
So selection produces information just like an IPO program.
Input, processing, and output is the basic function that all computing is based on.
Okay, so let's look at the six selection structures we have in C++.
We have one-way independent if statements.
So if this is true, do that or then do that.
We have two-way or either/or actions.
So this is--if this is true, do that; otherwise or else, do that.
We have sequential dependent if statements.
So if this is true, do that; else, if this is true, do that;
else, if neither of those are true, do the third thing.
We have nested or leveled decisions.
If A is true and if B is true, do something;
else, if A is true and B is false, do something else;
else, if A is false and B is true, do something;
else, if A is false and B is false, do something else.
Nested or leveled decision making.
We have labeled integral tests.
This is called the switch structure.
And finally, we have a selection expression.
This is called the conditional operator.
So we do a test.
If the test is true, this value is assigned to val.
If the test is false, this value is assigned to val.
Now, in looking at these six kinds of selection structures,
you have to understand that they're not all designed
to do exactly the same thing.
We have a rubric to decide which one is the right one to use.
The first rubric is we want to make sure that
whichever selection structure we use,
it produces the correct output.
That's kind of the non...we can't argue with that.
It has to produce the correct output.
The second thing we want to do is we want to make sure
that whichever selection structure we use,
that the code we produce is understandable
and it's maintainable, meaning when you come back to it,
you can change it and the code still works correctly.
You can understand it and maintain it.
Thirdly, we want to make sure we use the correct semantics.
Each of these statements says something
to a programmer who understands programming.
And so it's like learning an idiom in a new language.
If you're speaking French, there are idioms
that are French idioms.
You want to learn the idioms so when you say them,
the French speakers will understand you.
The same way with programming.
If you use a one-way independent if statement,
you may get all of your code correct.
It may be understandable and maintainable,
but it's not saying what you think it's saying,
even if it produces the correct output.
So using the correct semantics means using
the correct kind of selection structure
for the situation you're in.
And only then, after we've done those three,
do we want to fall back and think about,
"Oh, I want to make sure that this code is efficient
as it possibly could be."
Okay, so let's look at which one is the correct one
to use in each situation.
Imagine that you're writing the code that is going to process
this dialog box over here.
Notice it has these check boxes.
These check boxes mean that I could select one
or all of them or none of them.
So the decisions and what happens
based on that decision is truly independent.
When this happens, the only way to write these,
you can't use if/else, you can't use if/else/if,
you must use independent ifs.
So if the startup task pane is checked,
we're going to do whatever action is required for that.
That has nothing to do with whether
the layout was checked
or any of the other ones were checked.
And so independent ifs are the correct way to do this.
This is called the "guarded action" idiom.
In other words, we're only doing the action
if we pass the test at the start of the action.
The test condition is guarding
the action that we're doing.
This is the only case
that you should ever use independent ifs.
If this situation is not true,
using independent ifs is the wrong
semantics for that case.
So let's look at another one.
And beginning programmers, they learn the if statement
and they try and use the if statement,
the independent if statement, for everything.
What happens if you have an either/or decision
or a two-way branch?
For this, we want to use the
else statement. The reason we want to use
the else statement is because it covers all
possibilities. In other words, for
every possible input, you want to put it
in bucket A or bucket B.
If you try doing this with
independent if statements, you will
make a mistake when you write the second if statement
eventually. And that mistake will
either allow you to skip some inputs
or it will allow you to put an input
in both buckets, which you don't want
to do. So think of the situation of
paying someone overtime
when they get... or paying time
and a half when someone gets overtime, more than
40 hours a week. If you do it with
independent if statements, you're likely to write
if hours is less than 40,
pay them normal time.
Else... or if hours is greater than 40,
pay them overtime.
Well, you've just skipped the people whose hours were exactly
40. If you go back and you realize
you've skipped some people,
if hours less than or equal
to 40, pay them normally. If hours
greater or equal to 40, pay them overtime.
You've just paid the overtime people twice.
So again, if you use if/else,
someone will either be in the normal bucket
or the overtime bucket, and they will never be
in both buckets. And so it will
skip you, it will avoid
you doing situations where that problem occurs.
So let's do an exercise. This is called
the double sum exercise.
Let's go back to our code space. I need to restart
my code space because it stopped while I was
talking to you guys.
Let's see how long this
takes to do it.
[silence]
Okay, we were in last digit,
so I'm going to close last digit. We're going to
go into B, and we're going to do
the double sum problem.
So let's look
at the problem here.
We're going to write a function, which
given two int arguments, returns a sum
unless the two values are the same, we're going to return
double the sum.
Okay, so let's put our
name on this one.
So this
is going to take two int arguments,
so it's going to return an int.
Its name is double sum.
It's going to take two parameters,
so int a and
int b.
We're going to put the body on it.
We're going to create the result.
[typing]
And we're going to return the result.
And we're going to try it out to make sure we got it
correctly mechanically working.
So, right click, open a new integrated terminal.
Do make
test.
And it compiles
and runs correctly.
So we know we've got the mechanical parts.
Okay, so we want to say
two things here.
So if
a
is equal to b
I'm going to
set the result equal to
two times a plus b.
Else
I'm going to set the result
equal to a plus b.
Okay, so
this is relatively
straightforward.
It uses the correct semantics, if and else.
In other words, something a
either is equal to b or it's not equal to b.
And it's going to
go into one of these or the other.
So if we look back to our
four
rubric that we were looking at
to see if we've done it correctly.
We've seen that it produces the correct result.
And of course I'm going to check here to make sure it does produce the correct result.
So I'm going to do make test.
And yay,
we have 100%.
So it's pretty
understandable with if else.
I can see what's happening.
It's semantically correct. It's an either or decision.
It's not quite as efficient as I wanted.
So we could come back here, even though we have it done
correct and we're happy with it.
We might come back and say, you know, I don't like the fact that I'm calculating
a plus b twice.
I'm calculating a plus b twice.
And we could change that by
simply taking our initial result
and putting in a plus b.
Now we can
get rid of this else part all together.
Now I still
have an either or condition.
This is my else condition
and this is my if condition.
And so I don't have to say a plus b again.
I can say two times result like that.
So this is the initial value.
This is still an alternative action
even though I'm not using the else statement.
And it's somewhat more efficient.
Right? Somewhat more efficient.
It still has a slightly
it still has a slight chance
of error though. Remember our second
thing was to make sure it's maintainable.
What would that second chance of error be?
Well, because I'm using equals equals here, I'm
susceptible to doing that.
And if I do that, of course,
I break the first rule. Oh, actually I have the
warning set up so that
this will actually catch that.
As in C++ normally
it wouldn't catch that. So I have an extra warning set up
w error parenthesis
to catch that.
However, it's possible we couldn't catch that.
Right? It's possible we couldn't catch that.
And so
we might want to do something else.
We might want to write this if a not equal to b
result equals
a plus b
and then do the else part.
So I'm going to put that back the way I had it.
And I'm just going to rely
on the fact that my compiler here is catching that
so I don't have to worry about it.
OK,
let's go on to our next
kind of decision statement.
Our next kind of selection statement.
Multiway interdependent tests.
Now remember I said you should not
use if for
anything other than independent tests.
And in this case we have an
interdependent test. So if
percent greater than one
we get out of range. If percent is less than one we set
the result to a. If percent is less than ninety
we set the result to b. Set the result to c.
We set our result to 65. We're going to
set the result to d because this is true.
This one is false so we won't change it to f.
This one is also false so we won't change it
out of range. So we'll set the result to 65.
However, the test order
is significant. So notice I've just
changed the order of these two tests.
I've done 90 then 70 then 80.
And so this time
65 is less than 90 so I get a b.
65 is less than 70 so I get a d.
65 is less than 80
so I overwrite that d with a c
and I end up with a c out of this. Now you might be
happy about the fact that I've done this
but we've broken our first most important
rubric rule. The output
is not correct.
So this is not the correct way
to write interdependent tests.
If one test depends on the result
of both of the tests that came before it or after it
you have, are not supposed to use
independent if statements.
Instead, when only one
condition can be true, then you should
use if, else if,
else if, else if. These are
called ladder style if, else if statements.
They're ladder style because you can read down
them like the rungs of a ladder and you can
look at each condition and pick out the one
condition that could possibly
be true. And so this is
a program that is checking and turning
a number, "and," into a
word. One, two, three,
four billion, two hundred, and so forth.
So this is obviously correct.
The order matters, so you have to be
more careful. In other words,
because only one of them can be correct, you have to
make sure that you select kind of
from the left as the problems come in.
It's semantically correct. It says there will only
be one output, whereas the previous one
was not semantically correct. It's efficient
once the answer is found, there
is no more checking.
There is no more checking.
So let's go ahead and do that. This will be our
last exercise here. And we're going to use these
sequential if statements to check
on some dates for the
four seasons problem. So this is part
C.
So let me open four seasons. Let me
close that dash shell there.
Close that dash shell. And let's put our name
on the top of it.
And let's look at the problem for four seasons.
We're going to write a function named
season. We're given two integer arguments
representing a month and a day.
And we're going to
return the season for that month and day.
Assume that months are specified as an
integer between 1 and 12, 1 for January,
2 for February. And the day is specified between
1 and 31.
So we can write the skeleton.
So string
season
int month
int day
string result
Now,
when we wrote
the, when we had a result
that was an integer, we had to give it
a starting value. With the string
type, because it's a class type, we do not.
This will be the empty string.
So you don't need to write string result
equals quote quote. As a matter of fact,
you shouldn't do that.
That actually does, requires the compiler
or the run time to do some extra work.
And we're going to return our result.
I'm going to open a shell here.
And I'm going to make sure that this
compiles and runs.
So I'm going to do make test.
OK, so you can see that again I got
zero, but I don't care about that. All I care about
is the fact that this runs.
So here, now let's go look at
the conditions we want.
So we have, are going to return
winter, spring, summer, fall
or invalid. So we have
five possible outputs.
So we can go ahead and write the skeleton for that.
If something
we're going to set
the result to that.
Else if something else.
We're going to set the result to something else.
So one, two, three.
Else if something else.
Four. And
if it's none of those, it must be this one
down here.
OK, so this is the basic structure for
an if, else, if.
You notice how it looks just like a ladder here
that we could climb down. So which of these
cases should we handle first?
Which of these cases should we handle first?
Generally, if there is a
error case, you want to handle that first.
That means in all the other
if statements, you don't have to worry about
if the date is valid. So we're going to set
the result to invalid here.
And for all the rest of these,
we're just going to set them to the
so this is going to be winter.
Spring.
Summer.
Winter.
Spring.
Summer.
Winter.
And fall.
Summer.
Sorry.
And fall.
The nice thing is fall is done.
OK, so let's start way back up at
the
the next one.
So let's start our way back up at
start our way back up at
invalid.
So what does it take for a day to be invalid?
So we don't have to validate
each day to check each year's.
But a month of 13 or -1 or a day
less than
1 or 31
would not pass. So basically we have four conditions
here. So if
month less than 1 or
month greater than 12
or day less than 1
or day
greater than 31
we know that the day is invalid.
We know the day is invalid.
So now in all the rest of these I know that the
month is valid. So let's look at winter.
So if the date
falls between 12/16
and 13/15
so 12/16 is going to
be the first day of winter, December 16th
and 3/15 is going to be
the last day of winter.
So we're going to say if
month
equals 12
and
the day is greater than 15
or
if the month is January
it's winter, if it's February it's winter,
if it's before March 10th. So month
less than 3
or
the month equals
3 and day less
than or equal to 15 we're in
winter. Now when I get down
to this next one I have removed
all of the invalid dates. I've removed
all the winter dates and so I don't have to do
any of this checking anymore.
All I have to say is
if the month
is less than 6
or
the month is 6
and the day is less
than or equal to 15.
Why don't I have to check to see if the
month is less than 3? Why don't I have to
check for January, February and the early days of
March because I already handled them here.
They could not get down to this if statement. I've already
taken them out for spring.
Similarly for summer
if
the month is
less than 9, it's before
September or
the month equals 9 and the day is
less than or equal to 15.
Again I'm in summer. For the else one I don't even
have to worry about anything. Anything that's left
must be fall.
So this is how we do
sequential if statements.
Let's try it out and see if we got it right.
I may have made a mistake.
So we'll do make test.
I didn't make a mistake. We got 100% on that.
So you have everything here you need
to take your screenshots
and I will see you
for lecture 5.
.